pero
en la primera fila a la izquierda con
una boina roja en la cabeza
ahí está poli race and a bogotá me va
estas son las únicas imágenes que
tenemos del nuevo hombre fuerte al
frente el golpe está en burkina faso
poli race and ahogo da me va de 41 años
es teniente coronel del ejército
burkinés desde el pasado mes de
diciembre era comandante de la tercera
región militar del país encargada de la
seguridad de uagadugú la capital había
sido nombrado para este cargo por el
depuesto presidente y kaboré derrocado
por el golpe de estado
formado en francia paul henreid xandao
gotham iba se graduó de la escuela
militar de parís tiene un máster en
ciencias penales en el cea m el
conservatorio nacional de artes y
oficios
también es autor de un libro publicado
en junio en el que analiza las
estrategias anti terroristas en el sahel
y sus límites en 2015 se dice que
frustró un intento de golpe militar
contra la joven democracia de burkina
faso con otros oficiales hoy se
convierte en la cabeza de los golpistas